RUBENSTEIN: So Jason Furman is the 28th chairman
of the Council of Economic Advisors.
He assumed that position in August of 2013,
after being confirmed by the United States
Senate for the job.
He came to that position after having served
as deputy to the NEC from more or less the
beginning of the Obama administration, and
also as assistant the president for economic
policy.
He came to that position in the Obama administration
following having directed the economic policy
part of the transition, and also serving as
economic advisor during the campaign for president
that Mr. Obama-or President Obama ran.
Prior to the campaign, he was running the
Hamilton Project at Brookings Institution.
He also had experience in government before
that.
He also had worked in the Clinton administration.
In the Clinton administration he was at the
NEC, at the CEA, and also he worked with Joe
Stiglitz at the World Bank.
He is a graduate of Dalton School in New York,
Harvard College, London School of Economics,
Ph.D. from Harvard in Economics.
And Greg Mankiw was his thesis advisor.
He is the author of hundreds of articles-not
hundreds-but many, many articles in economic
policy, and written two books.
And he is a native of New York.
And it's my pleasure to introduce Jason Furman.
Thank you.
(Applause.)
FURMAN: Thank you, David, for that introduction.
Thank you to CFR for organizing this.
I was going to spend about 10 minutes talking
about our new report about the decline in
prime-age male labor force participation,
which is an issue that I address in the current
issue of Foreign Affairs.
Part of what brought me to this is every month
I brief the president on the jobs numbers.
And every month-not every month-almost every
month-I was actually in Germany last week-I
get to tell him how great the number of jobs
created were, get to tell him how great the
decline in the unemployment rate was, and
then there's always the labor force participation
rate, which has gone in the other direction.
So we've spent a lot of time over the last
many years really looking hard at that labor
force participation rate.
And one of the things we've learned is this
isn't just a consequence of the Great Recession
or something that's happened in the recovery
from it, but a lot of the trends going on
there have happened for a really long time.
And you see that most clearly for men, because
there you have sort of a fixed story without
some of the cultural shifts.
And then you see that being paralleled more
recently, in the last 15 years or so, for
women as well.
So you have a handout here.
And I'll take you through some of the findings
in our report, in terms of what the facts
are and how we interpret those facts.
On that first page you have there, you see
that the male labor force participation rate
has been declining steadily for 60 years.
It was 98 percent in the 1950s.
And now it's down to 88 percent.
So if you think about that the share of prime-age
men, that's age 25 to 54, who aren't working
has gone from 2 percent, which is virtually
none, up to 12 percent.
This isn't just people who, you know, don't
want-this isn't people who want a job and
are just sitting around doing something else
in the meantime.
You see the share of the people who say they
do not want a job and did not work last year
either.
So they don't have a-they're not in the workforce
now, and for the whole of the previous year
they didn't work either has actually gone
up.
The most important feature of this is the
one you also have on that handout, which is
it is primarily a result of people with less
education.
In the 1960s, and every time we have a chart
I show you as much data as we possibly can.
We go far as back as the statistics go.
For education that's 1964.
It didn't really matter whether you had a
bachelor's degree or a high school degree,
you participated at roughly 98 percent.
Since then, participation has drifted down
for people with a bachelor's or higher.
It's really plummeted for people with a high
school degree or less.
As you see on the next set of slides, this
is an issue that a lot of OECD countries-most
OECD countries have faced.
But in the United States, it's been more severe.
As you see on that top chart, we have the
third-lowest labor force participation rate
among the OECD countries.
We're tied with Italy, which is probably not
the labor markets that most would aspire to,
ahead of Israel, which has very significant
cultural differences, in particular certain
activities are defined as not working that
a lot of men are engaged in there.
We've also had a larger decline in our labor
force participation rate in all but one of
the OECD economies since 1990.
Now, the story's a little more nuanced than
that, in that we have a lower structural unemployment
rate than other countries, as you see in the
second figure.
So when you combine the two of those to look
at the share that aren't employed, we're also
towards the bottom of the OECD.
Some of the countries below us are probably
structurally ahead of the United States, they're
just in deeper recessions or slower recoveries
right now.
But the picture is also worrying.
So if you go to the next page, you'll see
the economics lecture portion of this talk
is three types of explanations.
The first type of explanation is an inward
shift of the supply curve.
And I'll explain what that could mean in a
moment.
But the important thing here is that predicts
that the quantity of labor would go down,
which is correct, but it also predicts that
the price would go up-the wages, in this case,
of less-skilled workers.
That's obviously not what we've seen.
Demand-driven says there's less demand for
less-skilled workers.
That would predict fewer of them would work,
and that their relative wages would fall.
That broadly matches the data.
And then finally, I'll come to some institutional
explanations, and try to flesh them out for
you.
But let's start on the next page with supply.
One of the most obvious candidates for supply
explanation is a lot more women are working
today than used to be working.
And so maybe you're married to a working woman
and you can take a little bit more time to
find a job, to stay in school, to care for
your children.
In theory, that's possible.
But if you look at that red line, despite
all these more women working today than in
the 1960s, the men who aren't participating
in the workforce don't seem to be able to
find them and marry them.
Less than a quarter of those men and married
to working women.
And that fraction has actually gone down over
time.
So this explanation goes in the opposite way
of what we're trying to explain.
The next possibility is government programs.
The most notable government program that goes
to this group is disability insurance.
And without doing any economics at all, the
problem with placing too much weight on disability
insurance as an explanation is the percentage
of men on disability insurance has gone up
from 1 percent to 3 percent.
So that's a 2 percentage point increase.
The decline in the labor force participation
rate has been 7 1/2 percentage points.
So at the very least you're explaining a little
bit less than-at most, I mean, you're explaining
less than a third of the decline.
We went through some modeling of counterfactual
scenarios, because not everyone on disability
insurance would have worked, not everybody
who's on disability insurance-you know, it
isn't causal in a number of different respects.
And you see those three lines.
And the lesson of those three lines is the
two counterfactuals look very similar to the
actual.
And when you try to do a causal analysis the
rise in DI explains maybe 0.3 to 0.5 percentage
points of this much larger decline.
And then other government programs, as you
see in the red line there, you're less likely
to get.
It's harder to get TANF.
It's harder to get SNAP.
It's harder to get just about any other government
support today.
So that also pushes in the opposite direction.
Having ruled out, for the most part, the supply-based
explanations, the next page gives you some
sense on the demand side.
And there's been a large literature on inequality
that's found that there's been skill-biased
technological change.
Technology complements the high-skilled people,
leading you to want to hire them and pay them
more, and hasn't done the same for people
with less skills.
But the process of globalization has created
a similar set of pressures.
And that could manifest itself both in lower
relative wages for people with less education
and in less employment prospects for them.
Also we've seen, as a result of shifts in
demand, big structural changes in the economy.
So manufacturing as a share of total employment
has fallen since World War II.
And that fall, a number of those men appear
to have, and you see this in some of the more
recent studies around trade and the China
shock, haven't found jobs in other sectors
of the economy.
Demand, though, I don't' think can fully explain
what we've seen, because you've seen a similar
demand shock when it comes to technology and
globalization in a wide range of countries-in
Europe, Japan, the United States.
But it's in the United States where you've
seen a larger decline in the labor force participation
rate to a lower rate than in other countries.
So I think it's not just the demand shock,
but now that demand shock is mediated by your
economic institutions that matters.
And if you turn to the next page, page 6,
those institutional explanations challenge
a certain amount of the longstanding, received,
you know, orthodox wisdom around the effective
functioning of labor markets.
That first set of indicators shows you the
U.S. percentile in the OECD, going for growth
indicators in a range of indicators.
And you see the United States has the least
overall labor market regulation, the least
employment protection, relatively low minimum
wage, relatively low state intervention.
So all the things you're supposed to do to
make your labor market function, according
to the traditional view, we do here, and we
do it better than other countries.
Where we do relatively badly is nationwide
paid leave.
We're the only OECD economy without it.
Expenditure on active labor market policies,
job search and the like, we spend 0.1 percent
of GDP compared to an OECD average of 0.6.
Tax on secondary earners, subsidies for child
care, all of these types of things that I
call the connective tissue that helps make
labor markets function seem like an important
part, that it's not just the flexible markets
themselves but the ability to have institutions
or policies that help people into jobs.
The next page shows another peculiarly American
aspect of this problem, and it is the rise
in the incarceration rate, which in the United
States is substantially higher than any of
the OECD countries.
In fact, you would have to extend this chart
out to show the Seychelles to find a country
that has a higher incarceration rate than
the United States.
When you're incarcerated, you are removed
from the numerator and the denominator of
the labor force participation numbers.
They don't count people in prison.
So that actually helps make our number look
a little bit better.
But when you're out of prison-and probably
about 5 (percent), 6 percent of the prime-age
male population was formerly incarcerated-you
are less likely to be able to find a job,
both because of the skills you lose in prison,
the stigma, but also lots of rules and regulations
that govern hiring in states across the country.
The final thing, though, I wanted to say is
I don't view any of this as inevitable.
I think this is, as the institutional explanations
stress, the result of a range of policy choices
that we have made, and we can make different
choices.
Now, our goal, of course, is not a hundred
percent of people participating a hundred
percent of the time.
If a 19-year-old goes to college instead of
in the workforce, that's not a bad thing.
And if a 75-year-old retires whereas instead
of in the workforce, that's not a bad thing
either.
But at 88 percent of prime-age men, I think
we're very clearly below the point where people
are, you know, participating in the way that
they should.
And that has ramifications not just for economic
growth but very severe ones for well-being
that go beyond probably just what you would
see in standard income statistics.
There's six different things that are in the
administration's agenda that would help deal
with this.
Aggregate demand is an important part of it.
Some of the connective tissue in labor markets-community
colleges, job training, work sharing, and
wage insurance.
The individual tax system could help, expanding
the EITC to childless workers or workers without
qualifying children, and also reducing what
is effectively a tax penalty on secondary
earners.
Creating more flexibility for workers in terms
of childcare, family leave, paid sick days
are all things that are more often associated
with female labor force participation but
would help with male as well.
There's a range of things which are much bigger
policies than just this issue alone, like
education, immigration reform, and criminal
justice reform, that would also have very
positive impacts for this.
And then finally, the conclusion I would make
is this idea that you have to accept large
increases in inequality because you don't
want to interfere with labor markets and the
way they function is something that I think
is basically debunked by this analysis.
So you basically lose the excuse to not do
anything about inequality because you're afraid
it would mess up your labor market.
And in fact, steps like raising the minimum
wage or collective bargaining and voice in
labor markets could actually raise wages and
expand labor supply and raise labor force
participation.
This is of course only one of the many economic
issues that we're trying to address, but it
does affect some of the big ones in terms
of growth, inequality, and just the perception
overall about how the economy is doing.
And I'm happy to talk about any of that with
you and everyone else.
(Applause.)
RUBENSTEIN: I have observed over the years
when presidents of the United States have
press conferences they give a little talk
in the beginning, and then the first questions
bear no relation to what the president talked
about.
(Laughter.)
So I'm not going to do that.
I'll get to some other questions, but I did
want to ask a few things about what you talked
about, but we have so many economic issues
to cover.
So on this, can you explain something that
was a little confusing to me until I did a
little research on it, but when the Bureau
of Labor Statistics comes out every month
and says, here's our unemployment rate and
here is the labor participation rate, they
will say, well, we have a 66 percent historical
labor participation rate; now it's 62.3 percent
or something.
You're using numbers for the prime-age category,
so you have-you're dealing with the different
numbers.
Can you explain the difference between the
numbers that we often get associated with
labor rate participation, the 66 (percent)
number-62.3 (percent) versus the 88 (percent)
number you're dealing with, OK?
FURMAN: Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, you can divide it by age and
you can divide it by gender.
And there have been very different dynamics
for all of those.
So if you look at women, their labor force
participation rate rose from when the data
started in 1948 through about 2000, then peaked
and started falling.
If you look at younger people, people below
the age of 25, you've seen their labor force
participation rates falling but you also see
more of them in college, so the share that
are either working or in school has stayed
the same.
You look at older people, people over 55,
and there has been a set of shifts in terms
of the types of jobs people have, the type
of health they have, and rules around Social
Security.
So their labor force participation has been
rising.
So there's so many different stories going
on based on different institutions and cultures.
That's why here we chose to focus on men between
the age of 25 and 54.
RUBENSTEIN: OK, so between 25 and 54 is what
your category is, but when the Bureau of Labor
Statistics comes out they use the-they use
everybody in the workforce, is that right?
And is that the better-
FURMAN: That's their headline, although if
you page through their thing, they do it.
And the word "prime-age men" was not the word
I came up with.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
FURMAN: So for anyone who is not included
in that age bracket-
RUBENSTEIN: All right, so-(laughter)-
FURMAN: -you should address your complaints
to them, not to me.
RUBENSTEIN: All right.
OK, so-no, I've already passed that concern
over the years when I got past that age.
(Laughter.)
So let me ask you about the issue of why this
is such a bad thing, because the theory would
be that if you don't have to work and you're
doing well-and maybe our economy is so wealthy
that people just don't feel a need to work.
They have inherited money, they've made enough
money.
So why is it clear that having a lower participation
rate is a bad thing?
FURMAN: I think it depends on who it is and
what their circumstances are.
So if we looked at a chart and we saw college-educated
men who are married to working women are the
ones who are not participating, you know,
I'd be a bit jealous-(laughter)-but say that
could be a perfectly great thing, and I'm
certainly not going to necessarily worry about
it as an economic policy and am not going
to judge the choices people make.
When you see it's people with a high school
degree or less, you see it's people who are
disproportionately in poverty, you look at
the time use-you don't see them spending more
time, you know, helping with children, helping
around the house-and then you look at the
studies of what, you know, prolonged unemployment
or non-employment does to people psychologically
and in terms of their ability to find future
employment, I think at that point it becomes
a worry.
RUBENSTEIN: So in your article in the Foreign
Affairs journal that the Council publishes-you
have an article about this, and in that article
you do talk about the licensing restrictions
that we often have to get jobs in the United
States.
You might elaborate on why that's a bit of
a problem.
FURMAN: Yeah.
We used to have about 5 percent of jobs in
this country you need a license for.
And I don't think any of us have a problem
with doctors, for example, needing a license.
Now it's up to 25 percent.
And while I respect people who would choose
to go to a florist or interior decorator that's
licensed, you know, I might be willing to
take my chances when it comes to those professions.
This makes it harder for people to get jobs.
It makes it harder for them to move from state
to state.
And it especially hurts a few groups, one
of them formerly incarcerated but also military
families and immigrants, and it makes the
overall labor market less fluid.
And when there's less people moving around,
moving between jobs, leaving jobs, finding
jobs, it means if you're unlucky enough to
lose a job in a recession, it's going to be
harder for you to cycle back into a new one,
and so recessions could potentially have more
long-term impacts on the labor market too.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
Now, in your article you also talk about France,
not normally cited as a great model for economic
capitalism.
But why are so many men and women in France
employed, relative to the United States, in
your view?
FURMAN: You know, I was asking two of the
top labor economists in France that question
a few weeks ago and they were somewhat puzzled
to find out that they came out ahead of the
United States.
And I want to be completely clear: I do not
think, you know, that we should be adopting
French labor market rules, and take everything
they do in France and apply it here.
What I do think, though, is that when it comes
to the function of labor markets, we need
to be less sure that we already know the answer
and a little bit more humble about, you know,
our system, some of its shortcomings, and
need for change.
RUBENSTEIN: Now, the trend you've talked about,
is it a trend that has been going on for quite
some time, and it's not something that any
administration-yours in the remaining six
months you have or even the next administration-can
have a dramatic effect on?
Or do you think somebody can have a dramatic
effect in one, two, or three years in changing
these numbers?
FURMAN: You know, certainly a lot of the ideas
we're talking of here are obviously ideas
for the future, and the president in his last
State of the Union said he was talking about
not just this year.
I think it would all add up and make a difference
over time.
But I think, frankly, a lot of economic policy,
whether you're talking about productivity
growth, inequality, or participation, is about
a few tenths here, a few tenths there, and
then they accumulate over time, and eventually
it does make a big difference.
RUBENSTEIN: All right, so if I could shift
to another subject for a moment, some people
think that the vote in England this week will
be a very significant economic event for the
world.
What is your view on the impact of a so-called
vote to exit the EU would be, on our economy
and the British and the-and the European economy?
FURMAN: All right, so just about every institution
that I'm aware of, with the possible exception
of the Council of Economic Advisors, has done
some estimate of the economic impact of Brexit.
And the thing that they all have in common
is a minus sign in front of them.
You know, you can see minus-1, minus-2, minus-8
percent on growth.
You see a range of things.
Part of why you don't know the answer as to
just how bad it would be for the economy is
you don't know what sort of deal they would
be able to negotiate.
But just classic trade theory gives you already
a few percentage points in terms of extra
barriers, less ability to locate people and
businesses where they should.
The thing that's scary, though, isn't the
classical trade theory, which plays out over
a longer period of time.
It's just look how much markets are moving
right now already on little bits of news and
polls.
Imagine, you know, what the potential impact
of an actual event could be on capital flows,
exchange rates, and spilling out periphery,
et cetera.
So I think this is a(n), you know, unnecessary
risk for the global economy.
RUBENSTEIN: You think we could have had a
more favorable impact on the vote if we had
said pull out, and then the British in response
to that would say-(laughter)-we don't want
to listen to the Yankees, we'll do the opposite?
(Laughter.)
That strategy wasn't considered?
FURMAN: I will-I will leave that for our international
political strategists.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
So, since the Obama administration's been
in office, you've been dealing with the effects
of the recession and recovering from that.
The recession technically ended in June of
2009.
Typically, we have recessions every seven
years in the United States, since World War
II, on average; obviously, some years you
go longer than that, or some periods.
But seven years from June of 2009 is June
of 2016, which happens to be this month.
So do you think we escape the seven-year jinx
and we can go for quite a while longer before
we get into a recession?
You don't see anything on the horizon that
will give us a recession?
FURMAN: I think the economic evidence is that
recession's a little bit like what an economist
would call a Poisson process, of each year
there is a certain probability that a recession
happens, and that probability doesn't go up
over time and doesn't go down over time.
And another way of putting that is expansions
don't die of old age.
So I still-so I think that, as a general economic
matter, is the way I think about it.
And then specifically, when I look at our
economy now, I think we are really far towards
our recovery.
We're much further than most of the other
economies that were affected by the recession.
But we're still not all the way there yet.
I still see slack in our labor market.
I still see more potential.
RUBENSTEIN: Since World War II, when we've
had recoveries from the recessions, we've
typically grown in the recovery period of
time 3 percent and 4 percent per annum.
In the Obama administration, we've never had
a year of 3 percent GDP growth.
Do you think the days of 3 percent or more
economic growth are behind us because our
economy's so big and we just can't grow at
3 and 4 percent anymore?
Or are there other reasons for that lower
growth?
FURMAN: I think the biggest difference is
just demographics-that if you look at, again,
this prime age population, 25 to 54, in the
1980s-and I'm doing this from memory and might
have this wrong-I think it was growing at
about 1 1/2 percent per year.
Now that age group is contracting and, you
know, the age group that's growing is the
people who are going into retirement.
So I think the biggest headwind for our growth
has been demographic.
And that's partly why this labor force participation
issue is so important, because the response
to demography can be to just accept slower
growth, which is what they appear to be doing
in Japan; it can be to try to encourage more
people to have children, which they're doing
in France; or it can be to try to get a larger
fraction of your population working or bring
new people in.
And that's why I think those steps are so
important.
RUBENSTEIN: So if Janet Yellen were to say
to you, you know, I'm not sure what to do
with interest rates the remainder of the year,
I need to know where the economy's going,
what is your view on the economy and what
do you think I should do about interest rates,
what would you tell her?
FURMAN: I would tell her that I respect her
independence and-(laughter)-she has an outstanding
staff.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
This year you would project economic growth
for the United States to be roughly 1 1/2
percent, or something like that?
FURMAN: Our last forecast was completed in
November of last year, published in February
in this year.
And even if I could remember it, I'd claim
to have forgotten it because the number would
be considerably higher than that.
But I still think above 2 percent for this
year.
RUBENSTEIN: Above 2 percent?
FURMAN: Yeah.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
And what do you think-
FURMAN: The second quarter, as you know is
tracking, you know, north of 2 1/2 percent
in a range of tracking indexes.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
What do you think, by the end of this administration,
the unemployment rate will be?
FURMAN: A lot lower than it was when it began.
(Laughter.)
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
All right.
But do you think the unemployment rate is
as relevant as it used to be?
Because it measures people who looked for
jobs in the last 30 days, as opposed to the
labor force participation rate and other things.
So when it goes below 5 percent, is it as
important an indicator as it once was, in
your view?
FURMAN: I think if there's only one labor
market indicator you're looking at, I think
you're much better off looking at the unemployment
rate because it really attempts to scale by
people who want jobs and can't find them.
Once you look at things like employment-population
ratio or labor force participation, you need
to make sure you're getting straight in your
head all these issues we've been talking about
of longer-term trends and cultural shifts
and shifting age structure and a whole bunch
of things.
I think if you do that well, that brings you
another, richer perspective.
But if you do it badly, it can mislead you.
RUBENSTEIN: Now, you've worked for President
Clinton and President Obama.
Who understands economic matters better?
(Laughter.)
FURMAN: You should ask Gene Sperling.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
All right.
So, with respect to the administration, you've
got six months to go.
Are there many economic policies that you
think you can pursue and adopt and get implemented
before the administration's over?
Is there any-what would you say your highest
economic priorities are now?
FURMAN: One thing we can certainly pass is
the Trans-Pacific Partnership.
And that's very important economically, very
important broader than that.
There is a range of other issues-whether it's
Zika, opioids, Puerto Rico-that are important
economically going through Congress.
There's global economic management.
We were just in China a few weeks ago engaging
with them on the big issues around exchange
rate, capacity, intellectual property, the
BIT.
So there's a range of international economic
relationships to put forward.
But one thing that we're trying to do at the
Council of Economic Advisors, in addition
to helping out with all of that, is things
like this report that we're discussing today,
that I don't expect to be the basis for legislative
action, you know, tomorrow or the next day,
but I do hope change what is possible in the
future.
RUBENSTEIN: So tell us, when you're the chairman
of the Council of Economic Advisors, your
job is to advise the president on economic
matters.
So, does he call you up and say, how is the
economy doing today?
Or how do you actually get information to
him?
And does he like to hear more about it, or
does he read more about it, or how do you
communicate with him?
FURMAN: We send him a lot of memos.
Every major piece of data-and "major" is defined
quite broadly-we get a day in advance.
We write up a one-page memo with our analysis.
That goes to him.
And, in our experience, he really reads those.
We do a lot of one-off memos on topics.
So labor force participation, for example,
we a few years ago did a memo that-you know,
on a range of issues there.
But we also meet with him, both short meetings
to brief him on the jobs number or the GDP
number, longer meetings that could either
be update on the global economy or on a particular
policy issue.
And in my experience, he's a great reader
and a great discusser.
So, you know, the best is, you know, get him
a memo in advance and then have a meeting,
and the meeting isn't plodding through a bunch
of facts really slowly but jumping straight
to discussing, you know, what the implications
are and what you can do about it.
RUBENSTEIN: So suppose he says something that's
wrong.
Do you say, well, Mr. President, you might
not understand that completely?
Or, you know, what's the best way to phrase
it to-
FURMAN: You know, fortunately that's just
never happened.
(Laughter.)
RUBENSTEIN: Never happened, never happened,
ah.
OK.
So if the next president of the United States,
whoever he or she might be, were to call you
up and say you've been in the White House,
actually, for eight years now; you know the
economy pretty well; tell me what I should
worry about right away, at the beginning of
my administration-what should I do to jumpstart
the economy or get the economy in pretty good
shape-what would you recommend to either party
to do?
FURMAN: You can always worry.
You know, we were talking about Brexit before,
so I'm worried about, you know, that this
week.
You know, you can worry about the 2nd quarter
GDP numbers.
You can worry about the next jobs number,
all of that.
But I think it's really important to not just
let those urgent matters swamp your attention,
and focus on some things that are really important.
And I think the three biggest drivers of middle
class incomes, which is our goal in economic
policy-middle class and people trying to get
into the middle class-are productivity growth,
inequality, and participation.
So this report is about one of those three.
But focus on, you know, what you can do to
add two-tenths of percent per year to our
productivity growth rate, and that'll take
care of a lot of other problems over time.
RUBENSTEIN: And income inequality, on that
subject, do you believe that there is a growing
gap in income equality?
Do you think it's a result of the recession
just creating this greater income equality,
and afterwards the effects were such that
the wealthy got wealthier and the poor got
poorer?
What was the reason that the income inequality
got to be so great?
FURMAN: That's a long topic.
Income inequality is a lot higher now than
it was in the 1970s.
So it's a longer-term thing, not quite as
long term as the participation, but it's a
longer-term thing.
It's big enough that I think there's space
for a lot of explanation.
Some people have, like, this is my one explanation.
They get really mad at anyone who has another.
I'm much more ecumenical and think, you know,
we can accommodate them all.
So technology is certainly one factor.
A slowdown in educational attainment is another
factor.
Globalization has put pressure on it.
The decline of labor unions.
The decline of the minimum wage.
Potentially some reduced competition in the
economy.
I think all of those have combined together
to cause it.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
Is deflation a problem that you worry about
very much now?
FURMAN: I'm not, frankly, that worried about
it right now in the United States.
We see our inflation rate moving up, not to
a point that worries me, but not in a deflationary
direction at all.
It's very different, of course, in Japan and
the euro zone, where I think it's a much greater
concern.
RUBENSTEIN: And in China, you said you were
there recently, what is your view of the likely
growth rate in China this year?
FURMAN: Whatever they want.
(Laughter.)
No-
RUBENSTEIN: Well, Alan Greenspan used to say
that the advantage of dealing with Chinese
numbers is you know them before the end of
the month.
But your view is-
FURMAN: No, you know, they have a big set
of economic challenges in terms of adjustment
they're trying to make to a consumer-oriented
economy, a service oriented economy.
They have a lot of resources to help meet
those challenges.
But you know, they're going to need to negotiate
them and then, you know, that's all against
a backdrop of it's harder to grow when you're
closer to the frontier.
And it's harder to grow when your demography
is as unfavorable as the Chinese demography
is.
So some of the advantages they've had over
the last decades they're not going to have.
So they're going to need-you know, figure
out, you know, more innovation, more consumer-driven,
more services.
RUBENSTEIN: What about Japan's demography?
Are you more worried about theirs?
FURMAN: Oh, now, theirs is, I mean, so worrying
you might give up worrying.
But they've-but, you know, one thing Japan's
done well, actually, is they've done a concerted
effort to increase women's participation in
the workforce.
And that's been reasonably successful.
And for prime-age women, they're basically
tied with the United States now, after being
way behind us.
RUBENSTEIN: So you're trained to be a professional
economist, you are.
So if you could have dinner with any person
who's ever been an economist, and just have
chance to spend dinner with that person, who
would you want to spend dinner with, other
than the people you work for?
FURMAN: Oh, all right, good.
I was about to name one of them, but that
would be embarrassing to say.
So I think John Maynard Keynes, just his breadth.
I mean, you could spend a bunch of time talking
about economics, and then you could switch
to a range of other topics.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
FURMAN: He was an investor too-successful
too.
RUBENSTEIN: He was.
Well, he lost money-
FURMAN: Successful, unsuccessful, successful,
unsuccessful.
RUBENSTEIN: Yeah.
He had his ups and downs.
But OK.
All right.
(Laughter.)
So let's have some questions.
OK.
Just please right here.
Identify yourself, your affiliation, and have
a simple question.
(Laughter.)
Q: Thank you very much.
It was a great discussion.
That's a compliment to you, David, as well,
Jason.
RUBENSTEIN: All right.
Thank you.
Q: And my name is Paula Stern.
And I'm affiliated with The Stern Group, Incorporated.
And my-
RUBENSTEIN: And a refugee of the Carter administration.
Q: Carter, and then Reagan designated me chairman.
So I'm bipartisan.
And we all are, as CFR is very definitely.
My question-this was so wonderful, as was
the last CEA report, particularly on inequality
and social immobility.
Thank you very much for all your service.
My question, since David asked so many wonderful
ones, is about the-your policies, particularly
the one regarding providing workers more ability
to use unemployment insurance to integrate
into a new job.
Now, this relates to the TPP as well, and
the trade adjustment assistance, which over
the years has had many proposals, all of which
have-(laughs)-either not been properly funded
or have not been put into place.
Do we need a whole new program for this economy
for what I guess I would consider the gig
economy, where everybody is kind of coming
in and going out and there's lots of churn,
and certainly the need to prepare?
Is there a program there that you would put
as a priority?
FURMAN: Mmm hmm.
So I think the-I think that's a great question.
We're doing one at time, right?
RUBENSTEIN: One at a time.
FURMAN: OK, great.
RUBENSTEIN: How come you didn't say any of
my questions were great?
But, geez, OK.
(Laughter.)
That must have been a really good question.
FURMAN: And what you're asking is very much
the motivation for a lot of the unemployment
insurance reforms we're talking about.
If you look at the fraction of people who
aren't-who are unemployed, but are getting,
are eligible for unemployment insurance, it's
much lower today than it was in the past,
in part because of those economic developments
you said.
So one thing is to make it, for example, if
you work part time, or if you have a shorter
work history, or things like that, that you're
more eligible for unemployment insurance.
And the particular line you called that there
was something where we'd like to have states
to have more flexibility to do innovative
things with their unemployment insurance including
not just you get it when you don't have a
job, but let's say you get an apprenticeship
that might lead to a job, maybe you carry
some of that money with you.
That will be an incentive for the employer
to hire you, an incentive for you to go onto
and get you back into the workforce.
And we've seen that successfully in some states.
And that has to be done, you know, carefully.
There's a lot of different twists and turns
in it.
But it's something we think, you know, is
a sensible thing to incorporate within the
existing program.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
Back here.
Stand up and please identify yourself.
And a mic.
Q: Thank you.
Adam Taylor with the World Bank Group.
So thank you.
Great overview.
I'm curious what happens when you separate
your data by race.
You mentioned gender.
But there are pronounced disparities in the
unemployment rate between black, white, Hispanic,
et cetera.
I'm curious if they're as pronounced in the
male, prime labor participation rate.
And if so, does the more general approach
of policy prescriptions that you outline,
is that enough?
Or does it require much more targeted prescriptions
in order to accelerate the participation rate
in order to catch up?
FURMAN: All right.
So thanks for that question.
We do have a chart which shows the prime-age
male labor force participation by race in
the report.
And I think there were copies of the report
floating around.
The basic thing that you see, which you probably
wouldn't be surprised, is that for black men
their labor force participation rate has fallen
a bit more than it has for white men, and
is a decent amount lower.
Hispanics, interestingly, it's been the opposite.
It's risen a little bit or been more stable.
And so Hispanic labor force participation
for prime-age men is now a tiny bit higher
than it is for white men.
That's also part of a broader fact that immigrants
are more likely to participate than non-immigrants,
which is one of, you know, the many economic
benefits of immigration reform.
In terms of the implications of that for policy,
certainly it says things like My Brother's
Keeper are-you know, that are more targeted
are very important.
But I wouldn't lose the bigger, macro issue
either.
If you look at the Great Recession, the biggest
impact on unemployment was on-you know, was
on African-Americans.
The unemployment rate went up from the mid
9s, I think, to about 16, which is-which is
terrible.
If you look at the recovery, the unemployment
rate for African-Americans actually fell more
quickly than the overall unemployment rate.
So there is a first to be fired, but also
a, you know, are benefitted by a broader economic
recovery and aggregate demand.
So I wouldn't lose sight of the aggregate
policies at all.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
Right here.
Q: Good afternoon.
Nicole Lamb-Hale, from Albright Stonebridge
Group.
What's the impact of the shared economy or
the sharing economy on U.S. economic outlook?
FURMAN: It's a-you have a better question
than I have an answer, which is we don't have
really great data to track that sector of
the economy.
Right now, it doesn't seem actually that large
relative to GDP, as it is relative to, you
know, news coverage and discussion of it,
or our own felt experience with it.
My expectation is that for the most part it
represents, you know, a set of innovations
and new sets of innovations are what you need
for productivity growth.
And that will help our economy.
Overall, it's created some challenges as well
if part of what's going on is regulatory arbitrage
and a way of, you know, unleveling the playing
field.
But even some of that is good if you take,
you know, a city that has fewer medallions-taxi
medallions today than it did in 1945 and give
people another way to travel around that circumvents,
you know, a captured system like that.
That breaks down a barrier to growth.
But I don't have any quantification.
RUBENSTEIN: By the way, on companies like
Uber and smartphones, all the other technological
devices we now use and services, why has that
not produced greater productivity in our economy?
We don't see great productivity growth.
Why is that?
FURMAN: I think some of it is it just isn't
that large a fraction of what we do.
So we spend I think something like 15 times
more a year on air travel than we do on taxi
and livery service.
So we're all really excited about, you know,
our Uber, but it, itself, within the transportation
sector, is just a small fraction of it, which
itself is a smaller fraction of everything
else.
And that's just true.
If you just add up GDP, GDP is building houses,
educating people, treating people in health
care.
There are a bunch of big sectors like that
and all the exciting stuff in Silicon Valley
is still a relatively small part of it overall.
RUBENSTEIN: And back here?
Get the mic right there.
Q: (Inaudible.)
RUBENSTEIN: And speak up.
Q: My question has to do with the things you
just mentioned.
Do you think we're in the middle of a tech
bubble?
FURMAN: You should ask the markets person
here that question.
(Laughter.)
(Inaudible)-a markets person.
RUBENSTEIN: Right here.
Q: Do you think we're in a tech bubble?
FURMAN: I think policymakers have done a notoriously
poor job trying to identify bubbles.
And part of our goal in policy is a broader
one of strengthening the fundamentals of the
economy.
I think there's a lot of really exciting things
going on in tech.
You know, as to the valuation of any particular
sector, I would completely defer to you, David.
RUBENSTEIN: I think that there are a fair
number of so-called unicorns that are not
going to be going public at the valuation
they currently exist at.
And I cannot possibly-what I think happened,
honestly, is that it used to be the case in
the technology world that if you were building
up a company you went-you took it public.
And when you took it public, that's when the
founders could get some profits and the investors
get profits.
When Facebook came along, for the first time
ever, in a meaningful way, people were able
to invest in the company significantly, buy
founders out and early investors out, and
provide liquidity without having to go public.
And those people that went in at $20 billion
and $30 billion-and Goldman had around a $50
billion valuation-they still made staggering
amounts of money.
So when that happened people said, I can invest
in these companies pre-IPO.
I don't have to wait for an IPO to cash out,
and I'm happy to have very high valuations,
because eventually they're all going to be
like Facebook.
And I think that produced a phenomenon where
everybody raced into these technology companies.
And while there are only a few Ubers-which
clearly are very unique companies-I don't
think they're all going to be Ubers or Facebooks.
So I do think that you're going to see some
of the air going out of some of these companies,
as I think you've already seen, but there
will be some truly transformative companies
like Uber.
Now, Uber's latest valuation is $62 billion.
So if you just went into the latest round
at $62 billion, to double your money you've
got to have $120 billion valuation.
And, you know, that's a high valuation.
There aren't that many companies in the world
with that kind of valuation.
But I do think that there are going to be
some people disappointed in these technology
companies but some people will make some money.
That's probably a longer answer than you wanted
and maybe not as satisfying.
FURMAN: Which one will you bid?
(Laughter.)
RUBENSTEIN: Well, I generally think professional
investors just have a hard time going into
these companies with these very high valuations.
We probably would rather miss on the upside
than be looking like an idiot and going down.
So I think you're not seeing a lot of professional
investors, pension funds, and others going
into these high valuations, but there are
individual investors that make a lot of money
out of Facebook and some other pre-IPO deals.
And, you know, so there's some people taking
bets on them.
But a lot of money that's coming in now is
foreign money.
A lot of people around the world observed
that Facebook did very well, and they don't
have an equivalent of Facebook in their own
country.
So a lot of the money that's coming in now
is foreign money.
It's sovereign wealth fund money, foreign
pension fund money, and high net-worth money
coming in to, I think, build up the valuations
of some of these companies.
Yes, right here.
Q: Odeh Aburdene, the Capital Group.
Jason, in 2008-2009 David was very negative
on European banks.
He told me to short them-the Credit Suisse
and Deutsch Bank.
These banks continue to have problems.
If you look at their price today, they're
way down.
What is the outlook for these huge European
banks in view of the economic slowdown in
Europe?
FURMAN: Look, I think if you're listing the
things people are worried about in the global
economy, the European banks and certainly
the banks in certain countries in Europe are
unfortunately on that list in a way that U.S.
banks aren't.
And that's a reflection of we very early,
you know, did a stress test and did an honest
accounting of what the capital needs were
in our banks.
We put a lot of public effort and complementary
private effort into recapitalizing the banks,
and now they have, you know, not just more
capital but also financial situations that
people are reasonably trusting of.
Europe has gotten a decent amount better in
that regard.
They eventually, after a few attempts, got
their stress tests basically right.
They have seen more capital.
It's more on, you know, some of the issues
on the asset side of some of their balance
sheets.
But, you know, I think it does remain a concern
and something that they need to focus on.
RUBENSTEIN: Great.
Yes, back here?
Q: Great.
Tom Bollyky from the Council on Foreign Relations.
Thank you for the great conversation.
You brought up the Trans-Pacific Partnership
and trade.
And the Council of Economic Advisers has put
out-or in the past-reports including a full-throated
defense of how the U.S. has done under previous
trade agreements, including NAFTA.
One of the things that was striking about
that is it's different from the way the TPP
has been sold by the administration as a whole,
which starts with the premise typically that
the way the U.S. has done under recent trade
agreements including NAFTA has been problematic,
but that that those problems are addressed
in the TPP and that's the reason why we should
move forward.
Why hasn't the more full-throated defense
of how the U.S. has done in previous trade
agreements, including NAFTA, been part of
the selling job?
Can we move forward TPP while disavowing NAFTA
and previous U.S. trade agreements?
FURMAN: So we haven't done anything that is
explicitly an analysis of any given previous
trade agreement, including NAFTA.
What we've talked about is the overall large
benefits of trade in general and of expanding
trade: how tariffs have come down over time,
how the benefits are, in terms of producers
and export jobs, paying more, but also the
very progressive benefits on the consumption
side as well.
So I think making that broader case on trade
is important, but I also think it's really
important that TPP-no one in Congress will
have an up or down vote on trade or globalization.
That's not the thing that anyone is being
asked to vote on.
They're being asked to vote on a specific
agreement with a specific text and specific
provisions.
I think it's very important to keep the focus
on that.
And so whatever your views about all these
bigger, broader issues-you know, what do you
think about whether Malaysia should have stricter
labor laws than it has now?
What do you think about whether Vietnam should
have rules about state-owned enterprises that
they don't have now?
What do you think about, you know, Brunei
needs to have, you know, an open internet,
that Singapore will be party to an agreement-a
side agreement on currency?
You know, that's the questions that people
are going to need to vote on and need to make
their decision on.
And there, you know, in every one of the respects
I just cited, this agreement, you know, moves
forward from any of the previous ones.
So regardless of your views on them, this
is a way to have a more level playing field.
And that's the argument we've been trying
to make.
RUBENSTEIN: They should have considered for
TPP an acronym that would sound better, like
YES, Y-E-S, or GOOD, G-O-O-D-(laugher)-something
that, when you say it, it sounds really good.
"TPP" doesn't have-doesn't, you know, go off
your tongue that easy.
(Laughter.)
OK, yes, right here.
Q: Hi.
Nelson Cunningham, McLarty Associates.
Thanks for coming and doing this, Jason.
On page 6, the institutional explanations
with the OECD numbers, the numbers all sort
of roughly made sense to me except for the
very top one, which is "Barriers to Entrepreneurship."
And the U.S. had a number of 62, which seems
to suggest in the world, or at least in the
OECD world, that it's sort of in the middle
ranks of countries in terms of entrepreneurship,
which is certainly not how I think of the
U.S. compared to the other OECD countries.
FURMAN: Yep.
Q: Can you explain that number to us?
FURMAN: You know, I was puzzled by that too
and have meant to look into it more and don't
actually know the answer, so-but I'll get
back to you.
RUBENSTEIN: OK, back here.
Q: Thank you.
Rich Miller with Bloomberg.
Thanks very much for the presentation.
You alluded to this before, but I wondered
if you could expand on the role of immigration
in-both legal and illegal-in the fall in participation
rate, especially among the lesser-educated.
FURMAN: Mmm hmm.
Immigration has, you know, mostly likely helped
the labor force participation rate.
There's two aspects of it.
One is, people tend to come to this country
more in their working years.
You don't get a lot of 80-year old immigrants.
And you don't get a whole lot of, you know,
children coming here on their own either.
So the group of people you get is more demographically
favorable.
And then they're people who are-you know,
tend to be working really hard to be successful
and incorporate themselves into the U.S. economy,
and as a result tend to participate at a higher
rate than people that were born here.
So I think it has been something that's helped
it.
And if we had comprehensive, common-sense
immigration reform, it would continue to help
it going forward, both in terms of the age
of the people you're bringing, or propensity
to immigrate, but also the positive spillovers
that immigration has for other workers in
the economy, for their wages, and for growth
overall.
Q: But what would you think about the argument
that some would make, is that when you have
more immigration the immigrants are willing
to work at lower prices or lower salaries,
so therefore it's a disincentive for, let's
say, native-born Americans who don't want
to work at these lower prices, therefore they
just say I'll stay at home.
What do you think of that argument?
FURMAN: There's been-a lot of people have
taken a look at large influxes of immigrants,
whether it was from Cuba during the Mariel
boatlift, Algerians to France, Russian Jews
to Israel-you tend to see very little impact
of wages of people in the countries, that
those large influxes of immigration come to.
And that's because a lot of what immigrants
are doing actually complement the things that
native workers are doing.
I think it's also important that when you
look at something like common sense immigration
reform, that's not even what we're talking
about.
Most of what we're talking about is taking
the 11 million people who are here, who are
not documented, and giving them a path to
participate in the workforce and to become
citizens.
And that means they'll have more labor rules
applied to them, if anything will be less
able to bargain wages down.
RUBENSTEIN: And when I introduced you, I didn't
mention that your freshman year roommate was
Matt Damon.
Is that true?
FURMAN: I was grateful for that omission,
but it is true.
RUBENSTEIN: And what was he like?
(Laughter.)
Did you know he was going to be famous-
FURMAN: He was-I think in literally the first
conversation we had in front of Matthews in
Harvard Yard he told me I was really lucky
to have him as a roommate, because he was
almost certain to become a movie star.
And that wouldn't mean-he didn't mean in the
sense that years later you could have this
in my thing, the more practical that he'd
be leaving our room in the middle of the year
and it would be too late to replace him, so
I would have the whole thing to myself.
But it took him a little bit longer than he
had projected.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
All right.
Is he inviting you to any movie openings,
or he doesn't invite you to any movie openings?
FURMAN: We see each other from time to time.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
Right here, Lloyd.
Q: Lloyd Hand, King & Spalding.
I happened to be in the audience, because
our granddaughter graduated from MIT, when
Matt Damon made the commencement address.
He was terrific.
He had a particular poignant comment-
FURMAN: Did he get introduced as my former
roommate?
(Laughter.)
They thought maybe he had enough-
Q: He may have missed that part.
But for this particular audience, for which
the word nerd is an understood, he said: Before
people care about what you know, they want
to know about whether you care.
I thought that was a pretty good point.
He made a terrific speech.
It was a good mixture.
My question, you sort of demurred when David
asked you earlier about what policy prescriptions
you may have for future leaders.
I have a related question.
FURMAN: I just didn't want to take, like,
a couple hours and it deserved a more succinct
answer than I was capable-
Q: Of course, that would depend upon which
person you were advising.
But my question is this, as you-and you may
want to take your chairman's hat off to be
able to answer this.
But are there any particular issues, factors,
concerns that you've learned expressed from
the electorate-not DNR, but just that surprise
you and that provide maybe some lessons learned?
FURMAN: You know, I just-I mean, I don't know
that I'm surprised by it, but there's a decent
amount of economic discontent, as we all know,
and as we see affecting things.
The combination of the tax changes we've done
in this administration, both cutting taxes
at the bottom, raising them at the top, and
the Affordable Care Act are the biggest, you
know, progressive change-or among the biggest
progressive policy changes we've had in decades.
So they've really done a lot.
The economy's in, you know, much better shape
than it was in eight years ago.
But you still have a lot of discontent.
And I think some of that is wages aren't growing
as quickly as you'd like them to grow.
But some of it is this issue we're discussing
here today, when 60 years ago 2 percent of
men weren't in the workforce and now it's
12 percent of men.
That's a lot of people.
And so it can be for your typical person things
are just fine, but you have a very large group
for whom it is very far from fine.
You know, I think that's screaming out for
attention and screaming out for us to do something
about it.
RUBENSTEIN: Yes, right here.
Q: The question-
RUBENSTEIN: We have-take a-
Q: Just one theory on the entrepreneurship.
We had the lowest level of people starting
businesses I think in the last 60 years.
And some of the explanation-my name's Kathleen
Kennedy Townsend.
And some of the explanation is that a lot
of students are-have so much student debt
that they can't access money that they would
have accessed to start businesses.
That's one of the challenges on entrepreneurship
that we've looked at.
What I was going to ask you about is that
union membership and how you can help with
that.
Because I think this is related to both income,
on one hand, and also social solidarity.
As you know, the group that you're working
with is also committing suicide at larger
rates than they ever had before, comparable
to the AIDS epidemic in the 1980s.
And part of-as union-being part of a union
raises your happiness levels, which I'm sure
you've seen the numbers on that.
So the extent that you can up unions' membership,
you get two-you got a twofer.
People are happier, and, two, they can get
better benefits.
So I'd love you to talk about that.
FURMAN: Yeah.
So I agree with that on substance.
And the CEA put out an issue brief on unions
and voice-worker voice in the economy more
broadly about six months ago that, you know,
brought together a lot of the evidence in
that area.
But a lot of what you do there isn't rocket
science.
It's changing a bunch of detailed rules about
how people signed up.
Certainly in the first two years of this administration,
the Employee Free Choice Act was before Congress.
It's something that, you know, couldn't get
60 votes in the Senate so it didn't make it
to the president's desk.
Since then we've tried to take steps like
the NLRB, and making sure that that's there
and that that's protected, and that that's
protecting people's ability to organize.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
We have time for one more question.
Carla, our co-chairman on the Council, will
have the last question.
Q: Thank you, David.
Carla Hills, Hills & Company, international
consultants.
I thought your presentation on the labor participation
was outstanding.
And we're having greater manufacturing output
with fewer workers.
But we also have a recording of job shortages-serious
job shortages, which don't need a doctorate
or a college degree.
They need training.
Is there any discussion going on about how
to get folks that have been dislodged from
manufacturing and are not screwing wheels
on autos, but who could come and fix my computer
and connect things, but they don't need a
doctorate to do it?
And is there any talk about giving a stipend,
the way that Latin American countries have
enlarged their middle class, by giving a stipend
to you, a family, to send your family to school.
But you don't get that stipend unless you
turn in the attendance record to show that
they did go to school.
And it's working.
Could we do something like that?
FURMAN: Mmm hmm.
So I think that's exactly the types of questions
we need to asking, because as I was trying
to show, just having a free market can be
a great thing in many respects, but it's not
going to, by itself, help us in the way that
we fully want institutions to help make the
labor market function.
When it comes to training, most of the dollars
there are spent by-privately, not by the government.
So part of what you want to do is work with
employers, get employers together with community
colleges, having community colleges train
people for places where there is demand rather
than, you know, sending their workers out
hoping-you know, the students out hoping that
they have some skill that somebody else would
want.
So that type of demand-driven training.
The vice president headed up an effort for
the president and has done a number of these
things.
And we've tried to, you know, integrate them
in where we're using existing federal dollars
today, as well as convene and work with others
to better coordinate.
In terms of some of the bigger ideas you cited,
I think that's intriguing and, you know, we're
thinking about.
RUBENSTEIN: OK.
So to keep the Council's happiness index high,
I'm going to end on time, 1:30.
I want to thank you, Jason, for the great
job you did today, and for the great job you're
doing for our country in the role as chairman
of the Council of Economic Advisors.
Thank you very much.
FURMAN: Thank you.
(Applause.)
(END)